I've told people to learn to use a
schedule.
And people often hate schedules because
they act as their own tyrants,
right?
They say we have to do this unpleasant
thing and then here's another unpleasant
thing you have to do.
And then you have to do this unpleasant
thing and you do that for about three
days and you think tail with this.
I'm not doing that.
You know,
and you fall off the wagon.
That isn't what you're supposed to do
with the schedule.
You're supposed to use it to design the
days that you would like to have if you
were taking care of yourself.
And so some of that is,
you know,
you wake up in the morning and you
think,
here's five things I have to do that if
I don't do my life will be worse.
It's like paying bills for example,
or,
or taking out the garbage.
It's like you have to do those because
otherwise things degenerate.
So you've got to put some of those in
the schedule.
Cause otherwise,
tomorrow is worse than today.
And that's a bad trajectory.
But you also want to build in things.
You know,
you've got to act in some sense,
like you're dealing with a relatively
recalcitrant nine year old.
It's like so well here's some things you
have to do,
but here's some things that if you do,
you could reward yourself with.
And if you get the balance there between
obligation and reward,
right,
then you'll find that you're motivated
to do the things.
And that's what you want to do.
You want to do that.
So it's sustainable across days and
weeks and months.
And so you've got to,
you got to treat yourself like a good
boss would treat a valued employee and
not like a tyrant would treat a slave
because the slave will rebel.
And you know,
people say,
well,
I don't follow through on my plans.
It's like,
well a,
they're probably not very well
formulated and maybe you're doing them
because of an external moral obligation
or something,
not really your plans,
right?
And B,
you're acting like a tyrant and a slave.
And that's a bad relationship to have
with yourself.
So you,
you want to treat yourself with some,
well,
the same way.
That's the golden rule,
right?
It treat yourself as you would treat
other people as you would have them.
Sorry.
Treat other people as you would like to
be treated.
It works both ways.
You also treat yourself like you treat
other people properly,
so that's a necessary thing.
And often people don't do that,
but the scheduling is really important.